[Música]
espectro todos los gemelos idénticos
piensan igual
[Música]
soy el gemelo más bonito tres dos uno
ahora educación
[Risas]
me gustaría no es común no ocurre
seguido Pero a veces es como yo nunca
usaría eso pero haz lo tuyo amigo estoy
de acuerdo contigo pero por otra parte
Qué es eso amigo Qué es eso No sé
si yo soy fea eres fea
yo misma y quiero que mi belleza sea
como que la gente piense que soy tan
bonita
[Risas]
en las redes sociales y en persona
[Música]
la misma altura
no siempre pero sí
yo sí lo he estado era más joven y me
comparaba mucho con mi hermana porque en
la escuela ella era la gemela que
recibía más atención de los chicos y de
los amigos y yo decía por qué no recibo
la misma atención que ella sí sentí
celos en el pasado pero ya no más no es
mi caso porque no me he sentido así pero
creo que nos vemos igual nunca antes he
pensado ella se ve mejor que yo y me
entristece que ella se haya sentido así
pero a veces veo sus fotos y pienso que
soy yo y eso es extraño
pero siento que no soy celoso en lo
absoluto Al fin y al cabo los dos somos
muy similares Pero somos individuos lo
quiero por sus diferencias y él me
quiere por las mías Sí sí ya saben estoy
un poco en desacuerdo
social y eso nunca me había pasado
siempre me había considerado como una
persona
3 2 1 ahora
yo no diría eso creo que luchar es una
palabra muy fuerte no me importa ser un
gemelo creo que es genial ser gemelo
pero también quiero saber cómo es ser yo
mismo y por eso le dije no vayas a la
misma universidad que yo pero entramos
en la misma y yo le dije no ve a otra
pero solo porque quiero saber cómo es ve
he sido un gemelo toda mi vida
y eso no me pasa Yo tengo mi
individualidad pero creo que los demás
pero o sea quién soy él sabe quién es
pero la gente no puede separarlo es
difícil para los demás separarnos como
somos tan parecidas
cómodas con eso yo sé quién soy somos
dos personas pero yo diría que en
realidad no sé quién realmente soy así
que por eso es que estamos aquí y me
siento de la misma manera siento que
como soy tan con dependiente no me
atrevo a salir de mi zona de Confort con
cosas que normalmente haría sin ella así
que si no estoy con ella no haría las
cosas que podría ser si no estoy con
ella
somos agresivas
creo que a veces desearía no ser gemela
porque no elegí serlo es como se me
obligarán hacer gemela a veces pienso
Qué pasaría si me separó Qué pasaría si
no fuera una gemela o si me fuera a otro
lugar o me mudar otro país a veces no me
gusta por la sociedad no por ella es por
la sociedad a veces las personas solas
así llamamos a la gente normal personas
solas no entienden preguntan Cómo hacer
una gemela y yo digo imagina que eres
una persona sola en un mundo de gemelos
cómo te sentirías el mundo está diseñado
para personas solas me gusta que seamos
gemelas porque somos muy cercanas me
gusta nuestra relación hablamos siempre
no cambiaría ese vínculo por nada siento
que tenemos esa experiencia
conocer un gemelo solo porque a él me
molesta y no quiero estar cerca de él
porque él me moleste No no es por eso
creo que en mi caso es por la curiosidad
de ser un gemelo solo o lo que sea
toda mi vida me han conocido como un
gemelo no como yo tengo curiosidad
sin ella
nunca estás solo a mí me pasa lo mismo
la única razón por la que estoy en esta
línea es porque a veces puede ser
difícil que nos vean como paquete Y eso
puede ser un poco frustrante es difícil
romper tu caparazón y decir Este soy yo
y nos cuesta salir si estamos en un
entorno social unimos
creo que si estamos en un entorno en el
que no me siento cómodo solo me volteo y
digo bien hablaré solo con él eso es
todo chicos
muy bien muy bien